c'est du moins tout à l'intérieur
ta dignité est ce que tu es la confiance
en toi tu vas tu te retrouves petit bain
voyante et jojo orient j'ai été abusé
pour alain fortier les choses n'ont pas
vraiment changé dix huit ans plus tard
il doute que les jeunes sportifs soient
maintenant mieux protégés décevant même
alarmant autant au niveau du provincial
et du fédéral
je ressens encore à l'heure actuelle
qu'une volonté politique de vouloir le
protéger
à l'échelle nationale le système sportif
s'appuie essentiellement sur l'équation
performances de ce médaille égale
financement cette culture du résultat
s'étend aux petites ligues et aux clubs
locaux
on le voit bien le hockey mineur par
exemple où il faut performer même très
jeune
selon plusieurs experts le système faire
fausse route et ouvre justement la voie
aux abus de toutes sortes
pourquoi ces entités l'aacs cinq sauts
sur la performance de recherche de
résultats
pourquoi si l'athlète lié bien dans son
milieu cela ne subit pas de violence
si l'athlète est respecté mais ils vont
performer
l'athlète mon enfance a été volé dans la
foulée de la sphère charest plusieurs
organismes comme l'association
canadienne des entraîneurs ont proposé
des mesures qui se veulent préventive il
faut que cela change et ça devient une
code universel pour tout le monde
par exemple qu'il y ait en tout temps
deux adultes en présence des enfants que
tous les entraîneurs suivent une
formation en ligne appelée priorités
jeunesse et que les antécédents
judiciaires soient vérifiés mais rien
n'est obligatoire
la première attente de 40 devrait être
demandé des questions sur la sécurité et
les processus et les politiques au sein
du club
s'ils n'ont pas les bonnes réponses il
faut trouver un autre club
mais la réalité n'est pas si simple par
exemple judo québec emploie six
personnes à temps plein et encadre 125
l'ubs à travers la province
le personnel a dû traiter une affaire
d'abus sexuels au début des années 2000
nous avons voulu savoir si les
antécédents judiciaires des entraîneurs
de tous les clubs affiliés sont
examinées avec les moyens qu'on a
présentement on peut pas aller
vérifier à chaque club on peut en fait
je vous dirais que je n'ai pas la
certitude que chaque entraîneur et
vérifier les organisations sportives
fina se démener donc ça prend clairement
une entité indépendante qui elle
pourrait permettre d'avoir une politique
globale qui verrait à son application
qui verra l'éducation des coachs par
rapport à cette problématique là selon
alain fortier une telle structure
aiderait aussi le partage de
l'information
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle chacune des
fédérations travail en silo et n'ont pas
tendance à se parler l'association
canadienne des entraîneurs et les
experts réclament aussi un registre
national
une base de données qui décrit les
sanctions comme ça se fait aux états
unis n'importe quelle personne qui a été
sanctionnée puisse pas changer de sport
changer de province changer de
territoire ou de niveau sportif pourquoi
commencer urgent d'agir
ça serait peut-être le temps aujourd'hui
qu'on se prenne en main pour être temps
que ça arrive pour marie malchelosse
radio canada montréal
m